now to the latest on former president
Trump's legal troubles today a judge
will hear arguments on his legal team's
latest request for an independent review
of the documents that were found at
Mar-A-Lago now that's after the
Department of Justice released his photo
showing clearly labeled secret documents
that it says that the former president
took the government also says the
documents were likely hidden from
investigators Robert Costas at the
justice department more on this story
Bob this story just keeps getting more
interesting by the day good morning to
you
good morning in its own filing the Trump
legal team called the FBI search of
Mar-A-Lago unnecessary and claimed the
justice department has mischaracterized
their interactions with investigators
but did not get in to much detail
the battle over a special master or
independent review of the Sea's
Mar-A-Lago documents has heated up with
filings and counter filings by the
justice department and Trump's lawyers
at issue not only what Trump had at his
home but the alleged conduct of his
attorneys the doj's filing late Tuesday
most strikingly laid out a possible case
that Trump's lawyers could face legal
vulnerability for allegedly obstructing
FBI agents and other officials as they
sought out records in obstruction here
according to the Department of Justice
is that they were told uh false facts
some legal experts say that the justice
department Spotlight on obstruction
means the probe could expand they were
told that all the documents have been
turned over it turned out they had not
been turned over not only that there
were twice as many documents not turned
over and they were all through the
personal residence in an insecure
location and documents classified at
some of the highest security
classifications in their Island
Wednesday night Trump's lawyers did
little to address possible obstruction
except to say one specific event the
June 3rd 2022 meeting has been
significantly mischaracterized a
reference to a key meeting where the doj
says a trump lawyer told investigators
that all sensitive documents had been
returned Trump's lawyers also reiterated
what they claimed are the former
president's rights to assert executive
privilege adding those determinations
are best served by the appointment of a
special Master during last month's surge
FBI agents retrieved more than 100
documents in over a dozen boxes or
containers in his residence including
some at the most restrictive levels many
republicans in Congress continue to
voice support for the former president
you never want to use the power of the
office to go after political adversaries
that would be wrong and so we just think
the doj should explain a great deal more
a Florida federal judge and Trump
appointee Eileen Cannon will make a
decision sometime in the coming days
about whether she will appoint a special
Master to review and return the evidence
collected at that Mar-A-Lago search
there will be a hearing this afternoon
in West Palm Beach a new Trump lawyer
Chris Keyes is expected to be part of
the Trump argument he's the former
Florida solicitor general now part of
Trump's legal operation Gail
uh Bob I'll take it thank you very much